welcome to this video courage for around
seven of my tournament in my account and
just to to be to be clear about it as
one or two people still wish me luck for
the rest of the round the tournament is
ended already for more than a week now
so it's just me recollecting the whole
tournament round by 1 i'm not playing
every round and then doing a video um
okay so this is round seven and yeah I
wasn't four and a half out of four half
out of six before this round so still a
very good result and there were still
slight chances for this very much
desired grant was the null but it pretty
much meant that out of the three
remaining rounds I would probably need
two and a half points and I need to have
some some luck with the pairing so that
I got a really good opposition um I mean
it was pretty much guaranteed that I got
very strong players but probably I even
needed some luck that I get some 2,600
play and there to just get the rating
average high okay anyway this round I
was paired with this Spanish player
renier Castellanos Rodriguez if i'm not
totally mispronouncing that he's rated
2474 um yeah younger Spanish play a very
dangerous player in this tournament in
an earlier round he had beaten on Julio
granda zuniga the number one seed in the
tournament 2670 Grandmaster very strong
player and my opponent he had beaten him
so um yep dangerous player um yeah I was
thinking in the preparation and well
let's start I mean he plays efore and I
saw that in the preparation he was
going from main lines and usually
playing very yeah not not outer sharp
chest but but very very much mainline
oriented openings and I was thinking
okay let's surprise the sky and these
were the first moves I mean I sometimes
play the Sicilian but I really did in
recent years and when I played it i
never played second to d6 up late night
see six months and then one or two games
but not d 6 and this pretty much shows
that yeah I want to play the night off I
want to play the dragon and this seems
that yeah this really has some surprised
him I mean I noticed immediately he
didn't play d4 here as he did in I don't
know I got like 50 or 60 games of him in
the open saying he always played before
but here he didn't maybe he was
suspecting some specific preparation you
know there was some specific preparation
of course I had some idea in the night
off that I wanted to play I am NOT a
huge night of expert but I wanted to
have the the element of surprise on my
side well he obviously as the saying
goes I think he smelled a rat and plate
Bishop c4 yeah a bit of a surprising
move but this is one of those lines that
has no name is very rarely played but
it's in fact quite good um if white is
looking for an alternative here on move
32 to the open Sicilian this is not a
bad line its am normally leading to this
type of position with d3 and here with
c3 that looks like white is playing an
Italian game yeah but black has played
c5 instead of e 5 um if you think about
the English opening 1 C for black rather
often place set up with e 5 and Bishop
c5 which is considered perfectly normal
it's called the cap off variation for
example if he would have played this
move here we really would have a car
of variation of the English with
reversed colors he however c3 is even
more logical as it limits my night and
it allows this typical Bishop retreat if
if necessary yeah this setup for white
is not not aiming at a quick victory of
course but it's a good way to to just
play a game yeah without any heavy
theory okay um I really didn't know any
specific lines and thought that probably
this should be riding boots g6 Bishop g7
you know played h3 here preventing any
Bishop g4 things castles castle say this
very normal and here um yeah I needed to
decide on a setup what should like do
now I mostly consider two three things
other things m1 is to try to play with
b5 and before fairly normal way to play
trying to emphasize the long diagonal
with b5 and be four black can also play
something like b6 and Bishop e7 just
trying to stay flexible this however I
didn't like so much as I thought that
probably wide in the long run will get
get to play deform and they don't want
to give him this kind of law center and
the third option um yeah which are
ultimately plate is e five um I mean I'm
not selecting from lines that and you I
was just thinking in general terms I
didn't know any Theory him but he 5 is
the move that I played and in fact I
looked it up it's one of the more
popular ones in the position um yeah
what is the idea of you five it has some
I'm very personal idea feel the personal
idea for me is to transpose back into a
position type that I know from the
reuleaux PES I very often play a 5-1 v4
almost exclusively actually yeah and
this is a very much ruler past position
the bishop on b3 is very typical it's
just like I had played Knight a5 in the
ROI c5 and returned this I got in
quicker now and oops and black also has
fianchetto with the bishop instead of
having it on g7 which is also quite nice
as in the Rue La Paz you quite often
play a rook e8 Bishop e7 f8 and Bishop
g7 so black has gained a bit of time
compared to the room but time is not
totally essential of course in this
opening as it is very closed um yeah you
might say ye five isn't this blocking
this diagonal that's true but it still
serves a very useful purpose this move
Adam I keep making this blink for some
reason it emphasizes the control over
deform and the White has a really hard
time now to break through with d4 in the
center which would be the natural way to
improve White's position as Black has so
many pieces pointing to what that white
would probably never manage this so on
it to make sure that black has a
foothold in the center and very long
term of everything's going according to
what black wants to once you achieve
there is d6d 5 just occupying the center
completely why does not have sufficient
control over the d5 square there is no
no Knight coming there for example yeah
so I think it's a very very decent way
to play as black played rookie one that
went age six yeah I wasn't totally sure
if this is a necessary move but it
mostly in most cases it is a it is
necessary or let's say it is useful
necessary is the wrong word sometimes
let's say rook e8 that there are their
ideas like 95 that can be can be
annoying or Bishop g5 can be annoying
pin okay I went h6 it's it's fairly
fairly new furnace standard 92 rookie 8
& a 3 plate yeah this is surprised me
bit but it is an interesting move there
was more expecting something like this
night III to d5 or somebody FD 5 at some
stage I am I was pretty pretty satisfied
with my person
a three is in fact an interesting tribe
it has a very specific idea that that I
saw of course and I wasn't sure ever
should just allow it or not at the end I
decided to just allow his idea because I
didn't think it was any em any big
problem I played Bishop to e6 what you
could argue is that yeah what is White's
next move yeah maybe Bishop b6 was a bit
too simplistic yeah the thing is after
but should be six let me let me show you
he took and he played before this was
the idea of this a3 move yeah preparing
this Queen side expansion with hindsight
you could say okay well black could
player useful something not very
committed let's say look be eight yeah
that's not doing very much but ok what
does this next move the thing is how
what white only has yeah maybe two or
three useful moves night f1 as well as
one it's not clear that this is helping
him getting in the night here maybe 93
controlling d5 could be a plan he could
play Bishop a2 after which Bishop e6
very much looks like black has gained a
move with Ruby aid in this case yeah
maybe Luke be a door a similar move
would have been interesting but I
thought okay let's play straightforward
chess this this is idea but it it really
does not bring any big benefits and I
think I was okay in this assessment um
okay I took on before this was my plan
when I played Bishop e6a be home and d5
this was a specific idea it's a bit and
come and maybe to capture I would term K
capture away from the from the center
cba be but it has a specific idea of
that with d5 black will get discount to
play in
in the center and I think blackheads is
very close to two equal him um he now
played the most Bishop to be to just
keeping the whole structure as is I was
more expecting him to play b5 but yeah
he didn't he didn't do that after b5 my
intention was to go to a hive that's not
a terribly attractive square I know but
very often the night there serves a very
specific perfect purpose the question is
what is whites whites play now if Y term
allows me to capture on e4 or in case
yella let's say he plays a move like
that for example and I would not that
sorry and I would initiate this kind of
exchange then the night has a good route
to c5 later and it also controls the
importancy foursquare so the night has a
useful role down and also in other cases
this might be a piece that disturbs wide
if you look at for example like this
kind of pollution here the night for
example also controlled see photo so
that night c4 has never possibility and
it has some ideas there and this I was
expecting this he played as mentioned
Bishop b2 which I didn't ya think to be
to be so dangerous on gas now I have to
move B 5 which are played and yeah this
does two things it prevents before b5
and it also plants in the long run to
play a 5 gaining space on the queenside
um what needs to be noted is that in
this position it is it is rather black
who has a slight space advantage with
those pawns in the center however this
somewhat expanded centers also a slight
liability
yeah there is some pressure on e5 and
there's also later some pressure on b5
we will see that after be five he played
a night to be 3 m's yeah looking at this
weekend square um yeah my answer was a
group to d6 this is what I had planned
beforehand also a reason why I went for
this whole procedure was taking on
before and d5 because i thought well
with this you actually get some purpose
to this record is six getting it quickly
to d6 and maybe um you some the default
on yeah i think fairly fairly normal
moves i also had a more simplistic way
to play which I didn't want to do black
can also just trade and play this
position maybe let's say Bishop fa dat
the end to to cover 95 um dia black has
nothing to fear it's just a very equal
position but well I thought rook t6 was
just a more interesting move why why not
and I mean I sure would have liked you
to win the game somehow but the whole
position type is not very much suited
for that it's a bit of a case where yeah
well if you if you don't go form for for
clean solutions yes black you're
probably just going to be worse without
any any specific play for example let's
let's take this position Queenie to now
it's black smooth and what I played is I
think I think probably yeah maybe it's
the best move home but it's the cleanest
one trying to to to clarify the
situation I played a five if you play
something else some some slow moves it's
not clear what you're doing you can keep
the tension somehow but it's not really
an apparent but this move should be I
mean I can I can play like let's say a
six yeah but what what is it doing yes
ways to improve bishop c1 bishop
here at night to see 5 yeah what I
thought a 5 is the most logical move and
I did some calculation of course because
it gets complicated in the center and
yeah it may be has maybe it has some
some technical problem who would see
this soon but this was very hard to see
in a practical game okay he took on a
five-night takes Knight takes rook takes
so we see we have some simplifications
here on the queenside and on the iphone
and quite easily the game could yet
could just evaporate and exchange almost
everything off here in exactly this
position there was some there was a
critical possibility what white could do
but this possibility for bite um yeah
needed to we be calculated very
precisely and we both didn't see them
the main point deep into the line which
is very excusable but then let's see he
took on a 5 this is the move that I
actually expected um but what can also
take on d5 and there I I wakely remember
what what I was thinking in the game I
thought rucca one yeah rookie a 195 and
here there's the case where white
basically must take on e5 as Blackie
threatening to play Knight a form with
the big advantage already so he must
take yeah it's a itself it strictly am
necessary yeah in this position if I now
go nite f4 there is the move Queen efore
intending rugae yeah night f4 is just
bad so I need to play rook um there is
it
help rookie 6 yeah this is her my notes
rookie 6 very very logical move printing
pinning the night then d for Bishop b5
de 59 f 4 and i remember that i saw this
line and continued it with Queen f3 and
Queen d2 this is what I saw in the game
and here i thought well okay this is
very active know where this is hanging
this is hanging and what is not terribly
well coordinated however in this
position White has a fantastic move
pointed out by by the engine and
whatever engine you say they will show
the move and this is almost impossible
for human player to to see King h2 is
the move and to really appreciate why
this is such a fantastic move you need
to see what happens if black takes on be
too at first this looks yep very very
good and simple because well okay if
there's the check something like this is
it's nothing really special this black
getting the e5 pawn even this year is
okay it's just totally equal but there
is a big point here after King edge to
Queen B to why it is not giving the
check white is playing rook a7 and this
is just a fantastic fantastic point
mm-hmm if the night moves there's Queen
f7 was checked made to come and if black
does something else I mean the only
booth that here we can really play as
queen bee three but if it tries to ya to
keep the night for example there's queen
bee 7 and this is already a false check
mate with the Queen and the rook
clearing the seventh-ranked v yeah a
fantastic point rugae 7
this is the relatively best moose
something like that black can try to
hold being a pawn down the best move
after this fantastic resource king h2 is
the move Knight d3 which probably gives
black decent chances to draw um I don't
want to extend this line unrealistically
far because well it's very tough to to
see it anyway something like that might
happen with sorry of not Queen age six
of course rooty to first something like
like that might happen where white is a
pawn up but it's very it's very
difficult to to win still black has
decent chances to draw it's it's a lot
of suffering but there are still very
practical drawing chances um this is
this whole line with it takes d5 it's
not totally forced for example here
black can also think of other moves like
27 for example it's also interesting but
rookie 6 is the most important line as
this is what we both certainly
calculated at least I did because it
looks like this looks fairly obvious
that black will get a very strong strong
player but this idea with luca a7 king
edge to Ruger's heaven is just just
exceptionally strong i'm not sure if it
would have happened in the game what i
would have played not sure maybe i would
have thought of other possibilities he
and then didn't play with Gracie I don't
know um he took on a five okay I
recaptured of course and now he captured
on e5 yeah this was another way to to
grab a pond and until I had a choice and
I wasn't totally sure what to do
and I took on a form de form and wonder
what I basically saw was what happened
in the game and I thought this should be
okay um maybe rookie six here in this
position is is even simpler yeah
something like him let's say take night
takes a deform and then taking here and
taking on c3 SF probably okay for black
and a bit simpler than the game but okay
I don't think that what I did was was
wrong I took here first but this would
have allowed wider to do something a bit
more complex than the game he recaptured
um because he lied on the line that that
happened in the game but this didn't
really work out for white um there was
an interesting alternative he and this
is the movie for this is actually what I
had expected if white wants to keep the
game really complicated it looks a bit
weird because while what is this the
bishop here looking at their own pawns
true but on the other hand yeah white
has two pawns that that you can target
b5 and deform well II for is securely
protected by the night it also means
that the night almost all the time needs
to stay on f6 to not give away the you
for pony and b5 is really a bit weak um
this would have been interesting I don't
think I'm a huge trouble but something
like this maybe something like this was
possible yeah and um I don't know I mean
in the game I thought maybe why this is
slightly better here probably true I
mean there are lines well we're black
holds some fairly comfortably at the end
let's say Bishop e3
on 95 with a with a counter-attack here
we should hear Andrew k6 this black
shirt should hold fairly comfortably
there there are some some points here
like this you know this is what also can
can be played but here the counter play
against III should secure a quality um
yeah default was interesting white could
have tried that well he captured and
then I went night h5 and this initiates
now a very concrete technical sequence
where the night is attacked and yeah the
bishop gets opened up and night f4 so
black gets lots of activity here and you
need to be precise now with calculation
the reason why maybe here here rookie 6
also was possible and maybe the easier
solution we see now after this white had
an additional possibility which we both
didn't see a very funny possibility
rucca a one was played ok the coming is
attacked and i only have one decent
square back to the eighth yeah this
introduces the additional idea of Rube
d2 and the pollution yeah and here he
pretty much instantly played the move
Knight to f3 which is totally natural
and what I expected yeah and I was
really shocked when I was checking the
game with with with the computer that he
had white the white in fact can take on
f7 I'm pretty much sure that I day I
would have been totally shocked if he
played that the good news is and it's
not winning for white but I think it's
pretty amazing that this possibility is
even in existence yeah black black
mistake em and the idea is just c5 and
now the rook here this bit of a
unbeknown unlucky piece where do you go
with the rook yeah if you if you move
let's say to be six young
White has some numerous ways to to
continue to continue the attack the
easiest is maybe something like we form
and then look a seven is in the mix yeah
there's G for trapping the night that's
quite a remarkable position where white
has quite some compensation there's also
ways to immediately lose like rook d to
e 6 check and wide we'll win something
like this is pretty terrible um yeah the
whole thing is okay for black due to the
move neither form i'm pretty sure that
when it would have come to that i would
have seen the move but but the latter
seven would have totally shocked me yeah
night f4 is it's just the most active
move and very often the most active move
is the best one Queenie form needs to be
played I mean okay you need to avoid
something like that Queenie for and now
black has rooked you want Jack getting
counter plane taking now is even Jack
winning for black you know Quincy one
checkmate so you need to go to here and
now after this Jack King e6 is very
important threatening Bishop takes a
five winning the Queen check this is
what will happen yeah and Tia black can
count on equality as he is just too
active yam this is just too active a
position or maybe Queen d3 it's not
really measuring this Bishop on a one is
just so bad that black will easily
easily hold this note that even a queen
trade is not a big problem as before as
a substantial threat in this case black
has no problem whatsoever for example if
you just form just to show this is
better to be avoided as he even black
has the better and
this is just the target check yeah with
this coming so it's a it's not advisable
for y to go for that yeah night f7 would
have been a shocking possibility really
but it didn't happen he pretty quickly
played Knight f3 yeah after that went
night f-4s planned not it didn't intend
to to cover the pony on b5 I mean you
need to get activity takes Andrew p6
this was what I had planned and yeah I
thought that it should pretty much be ok
for me as the the game continuation is
really really equal and the alternative
I thought would even lose which is not
the case okay look be six he had
originally intended as he told me
afterwards he had originally intended
Queen to a five and thought that this
would actually lose due to queen bee
eight funny enough I also thought it
would lose because while the bishop is
now trapped attacked twice and if you
move it there is this check and now the
bishop coming to see three with black
winning crocking both pieces here the
funny thing is why does not need to move
the bishop he has the move rookie one we
both missed that now look be to Brooke
t1 this actually losing for black so
yeah what what is what is the problem
what but should like do now I have king
age seven fortunately I didn't see that
it was a bit lucky that this is
available but ok black is so active that
he should be okay in a way but I didn't
see the concreteness um here for example
you know it's why it's movies he needs
to do something about the bishop and
black will easily Jack regain material
here and something like that until you
can can insert this move if you want
Queen some well not quite sure where
maybe here and then for example
something like this will regain
yeah like this check and this is also
falling pretty em pretty quickly um yeah
the thing is I mean I overlook this but
black is so active it's it's no wonder
that you will always regain the material
with with fine plane it's just funny
that we both overlook Group D 1 yeah
this is why he went 4-4 rook e8 nice
nice move okay Queen ahead no choice
Queen here yeah and in this position I
took only four as I had planned
beforehand um yeah just recapture and
black has a very active position now
obviously this is a bad piece and they
have all kinds of threats 92 queen bee
1983 very active my opponent afterwards
told me that he was a bit afraid of the
move Knight d3 just not taking
immediately but first activating the
night yeah this is in fact not a good
booth but I also hadn't seen the point
um yeah white actually has 92 and this
clarifies matters it covers a form and
black has no particularly a great move
in this position there also was a 5
which pretty much makes sure that white
is okay with white sometimes just
returning here if the bishop is not not
hanging or e6 is an idea yeah 93 is
simply not working he was afraid of
ghosts there but um okay this happened
Queen takes e4 and now queen d aid will
plate with a check and with a draw offer
yeah and I considered for a while if I
have some way to play for win in this
position because yeah obviously black is
very active but at the end it does not
make much sense to decline the draw yes
pretty quickly I am I will regain the c3
porn but this will also mean a trade
it's very tough to not take the pawn
Queen da checking age 7 and quindi one
all the way back is the best setup for
white yeah and now it does not make much
sense not to take the pawn something
like 90 can check for example King moves
and then and then just take it no with
the bishop actually is more precise um
yeah something like that and while there
is really nothing to play for in this
kind of position um yeah so I accepted
the draw there's no point in and trying
something that there is not that
something to try for something that is
not there yeah so draw in this game yeah
I say of course I would have liked to
win it to keep some chances for the
webmaster norm but still I thought it
was an interesting and and in pretty
well played game it didn't have any any
gross mistakes on or even in accuracies
from from both sides and it had some
some very nice lines that I was able to
show it's a more than 30 minute video
for 28 move so there was some some
interesting a Content that was not a
dull quick draw yeah this meant with
this draw that my already not very great
chances for GM norm were pretty much
pretty much gone the only possible
scenario that was left for the last two
rounds some after this game was that I
win then I get a pretty strong opponent
in round round eight I mean like above
2,500 win the game and then I would need
to get one of the absolute top guys like
granda zuniga with 2 670 and beaten yeah
so a very very unrealistic scenario um
yeah I wasn't terribly upset or anything
I mean you you only can score when
Marcin off every 30 everything is
falling your way at least them if a
player like me is competing for that who
is not well I'm not the 2500 player I
mean I'm
I'm a decent i am but i only can do
Emily could score Grandmaster norm if
I'm really lucky and everything works
together and well okay it's very good
it's a draw with black against 2480
players it's okay i mean it's it's what
i should be content with um yeah i mean
it would have been interesting to see
what would happen if he would have gone
for the open sicilian it pretty much
would have been a fistfight have leaf
but okay it didn't happen okay thanks
for watching I hope you enjoyed the game